vamos a hablar sobre las ecuaciones que
describen cómo funciona un capacitor y
luego veremos un ejemplo de cómo
funcionan estas ecuaciones la ecuación
básica de un capacitor dice que la carga
q en un capacitor es igual a la
capacitancia ce multiplicada por el
voltaje que pasa a través del capacitor
este es nuestro capacitor y digamos que
tiene un voltaje más menos b
y decimos que tiene una capacitancia de
valor ce y es una propiedad de este
dispositivo y se es igual
viendo la ecuación de aquí es igual a la
proporción de la carga almacenada en el
capacitor entre el voltaje que pasa a
través de este nos referimos a la carga
almacenada a que cuando la corriente
pasa por este capacitor va a dejar
cierta carga extra en esta parte de
arriba que estoy dibujando con signos
demás y tendrá su conjunto
correspondiente de cargas negativas aquí
abajo en la otra placa del capacitor a
esta colección de carga extra le vamos a
llamar pumas y a esta colección de carga
extra aquí abajo le vamos a llamar con
menos y van a tener el mismo valor
y decimos que cuando el capacitor está
en este estado va a almacenar esta carga
y nombramos cualquiera de estos números
de aquí que serán iguales pero con
signos opuestos y esto significa cuando
un capacitor almacena carga y ahora
quiero desarrollar un tipo de expresión
que relaciona la corriente que pasa por
un capacitor con el voltaje así que
queremos desarrollar una ecuación
característica y ve algo que corresponda
a la ley de ohm pero para el capacitor
que relaciona a la corriente con el
voltaje y vamos a hacerlo usando esta
ecuación pero aplicándole ciertos
cambios en particular vamos a cambiar el
voltaje de este capacitor y veremos qué
sucede acá y cuando decimos que vamos a
cambiar el voltaje quiere decir que
vamos a tener una condición
dv dt el cambio de voltaje entre el
cambio en el tiempo y puedo hacerlo
encontrando la derivada en ambos lados
de esta ecuación ya lo hice para este
lado y voy a hacerlo para este otro lado
y aquí me queda de q
dt y tomamos la derivada en ambos lados
para asegurarnos de que estamos tratando
igual ambos lados de la ecuación veamos
esta expresión que es bastante
interesante este es el cambio en la
carga entre el cambio en el tiempo y
esto es la corriente el símbolo de la
corriente es y así que dq
dt es la corriente por definición le
damos el símbolo y y esto va a ser igual
a c
dv dt y esta es una ecuación importante
básicamente es la relación y ve que
estábamos buscando la relación voltaje
corriente en un capacitor
y nos dice que la corriente es
proporcional y nuestra constante de
proporcionalidad es c y la corriente es
proporcional a la tasa de cambio de el
voltaje no al voltaje en sí mismo sino a
la tasa de cambio del voltaje
ahora veamos si podemos encontrar ave en
términos de alguna expresión que tenga
ahí y para hacerlo necesito eliminar
esta derivada de aquí y para hacerlo voy
a realizar la integral y para hacerlo
voy a calcular la integral de este lado
de la expresión y al mismo tiempo voy a
calcular la integral del otro lado de
esta igualdad para mantener todo igual y
nos queda la integral de y con respecto
al tiempo es igual a la integral de c
dv dt con respecto al tiempo de este
lado estos términos se cancelan y me
queda la integral de se debe por lo que
luce como una anti derivada es una
integral actuando como una anti derivada
y qué función tiene una derivada que sea
debe pues va a ser b así que voy a
reescribir este lado de la ecuación que
es una constante por lo que la voy a
sacar y aquí me queda ve solita y esto
es igual a la integral de i
dt así que aquí estamos desarrollando lo
que se llama la forma integral de la
ecuación y b del capacitor ahora tengo
que encontrar cuáles son los límites de
esta integral los límites de esta
integral son básicamente desde el tiempo
igual a menos infinito hasta el tiempo
igual al tiempo t mayúscula que digamos
es el tiempo actual y esto es igual a la
capacitancia por el voltaje quitamos se
lo ponemos del otro lado y ahora vamos a
poner a b del lado izquierdo así que me
queda de igual a 1 en 13 por la integral
del dt que va de menos infinito hasta t
mayúscula estate mayúscula es el tiempo
actual y esto nos dice que el voltaje en
un capacitor tiene que ver con la suma o
la integral de la corriente durante toda
su vida desde que el tiempo es igual a
menos infinito y esto no es muy
conveniente lo que vamos a hacer ahora
es
elegir un tiempo y le vamos a llamar de
igual a cero y vamos a decir que el
voltaje en el capacitor era igual a cero
y ahora lo que vamos a hacer es cambiar
el límite en nuestra integral de menos
infinito e igual a cero y ahora haremos
la integral desde cero hasta el tiempo
que nos interesa así que esta ecuación
va a lucir así lo único que hicimos fue
cambiar los límites de nuestra integral
ya tenemos la integral con los nuevos
límites pero ahora tenemos que tomar en
cuenta el tiempo antes de este igual a
cero y lo que vamos a hacer es
básicamente sumar de cero
cualquiera que sea esta vez cero va a
ser nuestro punto inicial en el tiempo
igual a cero y la integral nos lleva del
tiempo igual a cero hasta mi tiempo
igual a t el tiempo actual esta es la
forma integral de la ecuación del
capacitor y vamos a hacer un cambio más
esta es mi función con respecto a la t
mayúscula pero lo que yo quiero es tener
mi función en términos de t minúscula
así es como nos gusta que luzca esta
ecuación así que los límites de mi
integral van de cero hasta t minúscula y
ahora necesito encontrar un reemplazo
para esta de t puedo llamarla de forma
distinta esto es y ya esto le voy a
llamar tau que es una variable falsa de
tal más de cero y esta es la forma
integral de la ecuación del capacitor
tenemos la otra forma de la ecuación que
es igual a c mayúscula
dv de t
y estas son las dos formas de la
ecuación del capacitor ahora veremos un
ejemplo con esta ecuación simplemente
para ver cómo funciona cuando tenemos un
circuito con un capacitor